I did immediately regret it in a sense
where I called my mom and I apologized
to her and I said I'm so sorry I think I
killed your husband
but then there was also the sense of
like oh my gosh I don't have to keep
looking over my shoulders anymore I
don't have to live in this fear that
he's going to actually come after me
because it already happened
[Music]
I would kill them again
three two one go
Thomas Ogden was a beautiful person and
he was my friend and what happened was
an accident
and I would
um
I would give anything to Heaven back my
name is Forrest and I accidentally shot
and killed my best friend when I was 23
years old I felt like a shattered person
most of my life and there are still
shards missing
but I just spent the last five years
writing a very painful Memoir it gave me
an opportunity to visit a lot of past
trauma I feel in a strong space to be a
support for other survivors and create
positivity in the world
all my killing has been in the time of
War so I I agree with what I've done
what I do it again I would because if I
didn't kill that individual they would
have killed me or somebody else I was a
sniper so I'm looking after
a platoon of 20 30 guys sometimes as
small as six guys but I don't like
strongly agree with it because of the
after effects like what it did to me
mentally you know I was the first person
I killed I was 18 and I didn't stop
until I was almost 25 so I don't regret
any of it I don't have any bad feelings
towards those individuals that I did
Kill they were just protecting their
Homeland just as much as I would too so
I would do it again to save my life or
somebody else's life I work in
healthcare what I do is I manage life
support so I'm the guy that pulls the
plug on just about everybody so I come
from a very different perspective I have
to do that for babies all the way to
like people attend their lives I've been
doing this for like over a dozen years
now so I'm like okay I've come to terms
of what the job is yeah the the crime
and how it happened it was not I didn't
go out to kill this person
um and now understanding the impact that
the the crime had not only on me but the
family of that person
um that was a human being that I killed
over some drugs right and his children
his family is being living still in the
absence of this person it was December
the 24th uh Christmas Eve night remember
me and a couple of my friends were
hanging out this particular car came up
um and the passenger in the car say hey
I want to buy some drugs from you so I
told one of my friends I'm like he's
known to be this person that will come
through the community and ask for 100
worth of drugs but he never has the
money and the guy did exactly what I
said he knocked the drugs out of my
friend's hand grabbed his arm and
started speeding off and my reaction at
that time was I pulled out the gun and I
started shooting into the car to get him
to release my friend and days later we
heard that the bullet that I shot into
the car actually killed him to that day
I will never forget December the 24th
when that happened a day before
Christmas
I would 100 do what I had to do over
again
because the guy was a Serial perpetrator
he was after so many women if he killed
me he would have went after my mom all
my family my nieces my nephews every one
of us until he literally got what he
wanted I'm Tara Newell I killed my
attacker dirty John Meehan in
self-defense I think it was really
interesting how there was one person
here who had experience prison reform
because to me my attacker would have
been in there if I hadn't killed him in
self-defense and it's really interesting
to hear about how there are people in
there who are able to rehabilitate I
immediately regretted it
three two one go
why do I strongly disagree yeah like I
said I was a young kid I was 18
um the first guy I killed was uh with
the 50 cal like machine gun I was
expecting it to be like the movies where
you have this like feeling of when you
kill someone and it wasn't there I
didn't really feel anything it wasn't
until like that night I had this weird
dream uh the guy who I shot became the
ceiling fan in my room his arms and legs
were the blades his head was the center
of the fan and I watched him spin faster
and faster until he tore apart and
covered me and
what he used to be was left of him
um but no I didn't feel anything there
was nothing like to feel I knew that was
the beginning of something that I was
probably going to have to do for a while
um no attachment at the time I can't
agree with you on that I mean it
identify with that because my first
couple years inside of prison I detached
from it completely when people would
mention his name I would like don't see
him as a human being and that was very
insensitive when I look back at it now
right but I look and say that that was a
way of me coping with the situation at
that time I did immediately regret it in
a sense where I called my mom and I
apologized to her and I said I'm so
sorry I think I killed your husband
so there was that but then there was
also the sense of like oh my gosh I
don't have to keep looking over my
shoulders anymore I don't have to live
in this fear that he's going to actually
come after me because it already
happened
sometimes family members don't agree
with the decision and that decision is
sometimes taken away from them being
called every name of the book as I'm
walking in there but if they just don't
agree and then I'm like I just have to
go do this now you know but it doesn't
feel good or like I'm not necessarily
agreeing with this I'm like I'm like I
disagree you know uh the level of
heartbreak that I felt uh immediately
after that gunshot
um was indescribable
and
uh
I don't know if
any of you have saw red before but I
actually saw red
um
and it was the most horrific thing I've
ever seen experienced witnessed felt in
my life I got charged with first degree
murder that night and I was looking at
doing 35 to life here in California I
couldn't even process that there was
just so much a combination of horror and
grief
immediately
I am desensitized to death
three two one go
somewhat agree why is that yeah why is
that I do a lot of volunteer work and
the amount of people who are dying from
drug overdoses and suicides right now in
the arena of trauma it's be becoming
difficult for me
to feel anything anymore with the amount
of people that we're losing that we
don't have to for me it was almost like
playing God you know I determined the
time place when I'm going to take that
person off this planet and it put things
into perspective for me too that I could
be going to any certain time like when
you have the pool you know it's you
don't know when that card is going to be
pulled so I've learned to Value it more
and know that it's very fragile very
frail and to not feel anything towards
killing someone would probably be more
devastating to me than actually taking
to life it's not feeling hold on I need
to clarify something I just want to be
very clear that being desensitized in no
way means that I don't value life yeah
it's just difficult to feel the morning
over and over again yeah yeah like I
agree with you like there will be
certain stories that I'm like oh my gosh
I can't believe that happened but if
someone just tells me like oh I that
person died of a heart attack I'm just
like oh okay
like it just like there's no traumatic
incident with that so I'm like my brain
just disassociates and it's like okay oh
they died naturally so and uh from where
I come from like I I get to know a lot
of these people if I don't get to know
them I get to know their family members
like very intimately it's not immediate
like oh you're coming in and they're
gonna they're gonna go no it's it's like
weeks months I've had somebody like uh
their their five-year-old son and he was
in the room and I'm like uh I gotta take
your mom away now and it's like after
that I'm like oh my God I'll go call my
mom or I go call my dad it's like it's
really heavy but I feel like you said
like a sense of maximization of like
I don't know what my number is going to
be called because even if I'm working
the emergency room we work on somebody
for two hours and like we really can't
do anything anymore and I'm like just
like that
I remember this one
patient it was very much like nobody was
there we did they just found him on the
street didn't even have a wallet it was
clinically Dead brain wise so we
couldn't really do anything anymore me
the nurse and the doctor just stayed in
that room until
there's a heart rate left because we
didn't want to see him um leave by
himself that was um one of the most uh
what's it called sobering moments too
it's like as much as it was nice for us
to do that I just don't want strangers
around me you know seeing me off I think
for me as a teenager
um selling drugs just hanging in the
Screech just living a lifestyle that I
didn't care if I killed someone I was
very desensitized I didn't care I didn't
feel no remorse for it and this is part
of it was part of my own personal
development I needed to find a way to
attach to that so I started doing this
hospice training inside of one of their
prisons by listening to these
individuals tell their story in the
regrets that they were living with in
their process of transitioning it gave
me a sense of a value of life now you
know um and it shifted my mindset as
this teenager who was very callous
towards um life at that time I've taken
care of people they're B they're being
on life support they'll hang on for like
a very long time until one specific
person sometimes it's
and then I'm like I can't explain that I
could take them off and they'll be their
heart rate will keep going and going and
going one of the guys I was working with
in the prison um he wanted to see his
sister so this dude held on until like
his sister walked into the room and and
she and he was like not consciously but
like she spoke to him and she started
like talking to him and you started
seeing him move and then soon as she was
like she was like I'm leaving
and like within minutes it's gonna like
transition yeah with my situation I made
him brain dead and so he was in the
hospital and then when they pulled the
plug on him my mom literally had to tell
him it's okay to go now and then he left
yeah yeah I think we're more than just
our brain right we're Spirits living in
flesh man yeah that's all
I am also a victim
three two one go
I feel weird I'm not trying to single
together but I feel like I have to be
over here because the guy came after me
I was in a parking garage I was just
trying to go to the Jason Aldean concert
that night he started attacking me
stabbing me and I fought back and I won
so I didn't ask for any of that I
honestly hated the guy and I wished he
would be dead but I never wanted to
unalive or take someone's life my first
couple years in prison I saw myself as
the victim right and that was again a
way of me coping as I continue to do
some interpersonal work I realized that
I was not a victim that I still made a
choice in the crime that I committed
right but I'm just I just wanted to
share that like I I wanted to run over
there but I'm in this place of healing
and Reconciliation and I had to like
move away from the victimization mindset
and take ownership for the decision that
I actually pulled the trigger
um committed the crime unfortunately
someone died and I have to take that on
because that's part of my own personal
growth and development I remember on a
Friday night three years into my
incarceration I remember laying in my
bed watching this show called Dateline
and for the first time I heard a mother
really expressing her loss for the loss
of her loved one and that's was that
moment in my life where I connected with
that I'm like yo I did the same thing
and I and I went into a fetus position
and I started praying and all I kept
hearing in in my hearing this voice
saying I have forgiven you you have to
ask Carrie the guy that you killed to
forgive you and in that process this is
where I begin I remember saying Gary
would you forgive me and I literally
felt like in that moment he forgave me
and I heard it and it's almost like a
weight was lifted off of me and that's
when I began this this cleansing this
this process of healing and moving
forward and and finding a purpose and
finding my voice and all of that that
particular night inside of that prison
when I surrendered to it now I don't
feel like I'm a victim for anything like
I chose that path started off on to be a
Navy SEAL when I was like in elementary
school my mom helped me make my first
ghillie suit when I was in the sixth
grade like it's something I've always
wanted to do and
I knew it came with that which was
more than likely having to kill someone
especially in the time of War yeah I'm
not a victim but the only thing I would
say is like they don't really prepare us
into doing the job that we do they you
know they do the data dating oh this is
what you do this where you try and all
that stuff and then now you're like oh
by the way the doctor wrote the order
um go take him off and now I gotta walk
in or like if it's a baby they're still
holding them in their hands and stuff
and like go take them off and so I never
really thought about it like nobody's
like talked to me or anything like by
the way uh this is where you're gonna
feel afterwards or like when you get
home after you clock out and everything
like that yeah we didn't have a handbook
on that either like yeah yeah they teach
you how to kill but there's no how to
process how to process it
I have profited from the murder
three two one
go
make me feel bad about this
why don't you like that word I don't
like it all right a um I don't think it
applies universally yeah right
um homicide is a universal term as far
as profiting from any part of my story
no
um I've spent the last four years five
years struggling to write and publish a
book and I spent about 80 G's on it and
made about four thousand and that that's
not why I did it I did it because I want
to help people but I don't think that
it's very common for people to profit
off of recovery from stuff right well
maybe it is I don't know um I guess I'll
go over here then my attacker my show
got made into a podcast called Dirty
John and then it got made into a
documentary a TV show on Bravo and now
on Netflix and so
I felt like I've been exploited in the
sense because I did not make anything
off of the podcast although people think
I profited off my story I did not but
also and you get paid to take his life
no not at all okay so if you profited
off of any if I profit off of anything
it's my hard work afterwards yeah it's
my hard work to share and be of service
so no you didn't people hate profit
sometimes they just hate you just
because you made money yeah for me as a
as a speaker and a trainer
um I struggled with that for a long time
right you know I committed this crime
and yes I did all of the work that I
have done to become the man that I am
today but then I sometimes I don't I
don't sleep at night right knowing that
I've made this bag of money or whatever
any money I get I want to be able to
live comfortable it's not about getting
something luxury how could I help some
young person so we do do the non-profit
work but my five-year goal now is
continue goal is that you would have a
profit I make is to create a foundation
in honor of Gary going back to that
promise I made to him almost 30 years
ago inside of a prison cell it initially
started as me writing a journal my dad
suggested I I did that I was going
through a hard time self-medicating and
contemplating some bad decisions started
off as that and it got picked up by a
major book publishing company and it
went on to become essentially like an
autobiography of that time in after
accomplishing that I went on to what I
do currently which is write you know
novels and stuff like that not based on
my life because I did feel a certain way
about it of profiting from killing you
know I get what you're saying too all
the work that you put in there after
that's on you you know but I also see it
as well I killed all these guys and I
wrote a book about it and profited from
it were you in E4 E5 E5 yeah that's all
the money you made of it right one once
again complex issue that gets lumped
together if somebody's has money they
must be doing something for profit and I
think
where an answer is I mean do we follow
purpose or do we follow the money it's
going to go away when I die it's not
going to matter what's going to matter
when I die is what I did am I proud of
myself the things that I did I open see
money more of like as an amplifier for
what people can do what reach they can
do yeah we took a big impact on now like
knowing like when I go speak to young
people today about gun violence and
about my story the only way they can get
out of a situation is if I have money
yeah yeah right that can create a safe
space for them to go after school so I
have to make some money to be able to do
that you know I mean but I don't want to
make a bunch of money and I'm living
here and then I'll walk into the
community and say hey young kids put the
guns down prison say no to prison and I
drive away in this nice car and forget
about it right so that's where I'm at
like purpose for me is about how do I
make impact in the lives of the people
that I serve
taking a life was part of God's plan for
me
[Music]
three two one go
oh
I'm unclear with that one that's that's
why I'm like this
yeah
that's I wouldn't be who I am today to
be able to have the experience that I've
had and become who I've become uh
without taking a life I learned my
lesson after all the killing you know my
last deployment dropped
over 30 guys 33 people and who knows how
many before that but what I had to get
through and overcome to stand here today
far exceeded anything I've done in the
military being emotionally somewhat
strong and yeah what I've had to
overcome has been a lot of dark nights
where didn't think I was going to be
here you know well I'm like this yeah I
know what you mean though yeah I don't
want it to be perceived to be
insensitive about the victims yeah yeah
right but I know on this part of me I
look at my friends who I grew up with at
19 years old and I did 22 years in
prison and when I came back home they
were at the same at the same spot under
the same tree we sold drugs at but then
if I over here I think about the gold
diggers family because you know their
son is like oh God that's in my son my
brother or my son to die you know what I
mean so but if you believe in God then
that would be
he already knew that before I get that
far I mean I'm a spiritual man right but
I'm just like I don't want it to I don't
it's just that's that's my dilemma when
it comes
I don't think that he's letting some kid
be blown apart in Iraq because he's busy
helping me look for a parking space yeah
right I don't think that the realm of
the spirit is as concerned with human
Affairs I think that the sun rises and
sets for a reason yeah the in Rockets
through space at 40 000 miles an hour
with a bunch of rocks around it for a
reason and animals have Instinct for a
reason and I think human beings
and I think things just happen sometimes
there doesn't have to be meaning or a
plan but then it's harmful a person who
lost a loved one to wrap that for me in
my uh homicide is completely different
than most of you in this room is someone
died by me pulling this trigger
and and I can't say it was in God's plan
I pulled the trigger too yeah I thought
the gun was empty and I still can't wrap
my head
around a stupid decision like that even
though that it malfunctioned and acted
unloaded
had I done all the right things the four
safety rules it never would have
happened and I still I was nervous
coming here because I can't I don't know
what I was thinking I wasn't thinking
and I had no intent at all there's no
way I would have assumed put it to my
head
or at the floor or what I and I can't
remember ever doing that before or after
and
it was a mistake I think for me it was
part of my Dharma I'm a little bit more
spiritual so I think it was my life's
purpose to be honest
because of what I do today whenever I
speak I always have people contact me
and say that they left abusive
relationship or what I shared helped
them get out of their attack sharing
your story helps other people and yeah
you feel that yeah call the transparency
transports people yeah that's why I'm
like really honest about who I am
because there's someone else not just in
a physical prison but an emotional
mental prison and by hearing your story
hearing all of our stories it helps
transport them to another space of
showing that I can't escape this
particular prison after having this
discussion Lester
choose a side
[Laughter]
I don't think it's fair to make you
choose a side do you believe what you
believe I'm Gonna Stand just a little
bit
like respectful I really like what you
did man because we move in seconds and
inches yeah and measure progress and
yeah my eight years you know
that was kind of a lot what's up this
episode was just sort of intense and I
think I need a little time to debris now
life's got you down bad huh yeah just a
little you know sometimes I need a big
hug or some reassurance that everything
will be okay in the world you know here
try the Skylight app
maybe it can help you feel connected to
the universe a little more and help you
feel more grounded Skylight welcomes you
to discover more about yourself and your
spirituality regardless of your Life
Path and the stressful thoughts and
anxieties that may come with it with a
new YouTube channel and app Skylight is
focused on helping you meditate and calm
your thoughts when you need that extra
hug and if you don't know exactly what
spiritual self-care means to you yet
Skylight can be your new BFF to help you
explore that wait hold on this Skylight
video on living the fullest life before
you die take my money actually you won't
be eating that at all because Skylight
is like your new best friend there
whenever you need it and free of charge
so you can put your wallet away
anyway I've got to go now but I'm here
whenever you need me just visit me
anytime at youtube.com skylights your
life or the Skylight app at skylight.org
well thank you Skylight for sponsoring
this portion of the video
I'm ready to finish this episode now
there are enough resources for me to
heal
three two one go
when I was in the military it was uh
like looked down upon to
go seek mental help or anything dude
you'd get kicked off the team you know
in a heartbeat I don't want a guy who's
soft watching my back you know or what I
perceive at the time yeah
um after each deployment our therapist
was like a 18-wheeler truck full of kegs
of beer and more beer and 12 hours ago I
just took a life 21 years old at a strip
club in Atlanta
drinking you know till my eyes pop out
uh to cope we would talk to like a
psychiatrist but we were encouraged to
write down you know I didn't have this
emotion I didn't see this so we could
get home early to see our family but two
years ago two or three years ago I
decided to actually to talk to someone
and figure out why I was the way I was
because I wanted to change I didn't like
being
everywhere I went you know I'm looking
at everyone and
have a it's going to sound so bad but
I was polite to everybody who I met but
I always in the back of my mind had a
plan to kill them just in case the
situation presented itself if something
went South I've already mapped out and
planned for three different scenarios
how I would kill this person and I was
comfortable being in that state of mind
because it kept that
protection you know that wall up but
all right it gets it gets tiring after a
while to to always be that way you know
for me I look at this right I want to
run over here
um to the strongly disagree it's almost
because of the length of your sentence
and you like I was serving life I didn't
become eligible for most of the classes
in prison until I came down to my last
three years in prison right now I have
to run back over here to strongly agree
after being a person who's been released
from prison I've learned these different
things that now helped me to cope with
all of the stuff that comes with me uh
living inside of a prison not only being
um a person who took someone's life but
seeing other individuals get killed
inside of the prison right you see
people get stabbed in prison over some
of the simplest things no one would come
and talk to you about like was that
triggering for you how did you you saw
this person blood spill out over the
concrete nothing right this is why I
challenged the prison system anyone who
works in that prison environment to
create more Mental Health Services for
those in prison because yes that person
may have committed a violent crime but
we don't know their story I'm like that
with the military man there's not enough
in my my opinion it's not encouraged
enough yeah the VA helped me somewhat
right I'm not going to say the VA didn't
help but when I was suicidal I didn't
call the VA helpline because I didn't
want to sit here and fill out a strongly
agree and disagree form and wait in a
waiting room and I called another
brother and he sent me to a program
called save a warrior and I experienced
something it might sound weird called
initiation there the participant faces
their own death and they receive a
transitional object and something about
that changed my psyche and something
clicked and we did stuff like the
ceremony for the dead there where we
write the names of the people we've lost
and the people we've killed and we'd get
to cry and like feel and process and
become human again because War can break
us in prison can break us and make us
incomplete and not human and when we use
different modalities abilities to place
that Humanity back together then we can
have Community right and Community is
the antidote to a lot of human suffering
yes sir I wrote a 12-step program for
vets and First Responders called Sparta
Suicide Prevention and resilience
training Anonymous we meet once a week
and and I used to think there wasn't
enough resources and the more I get
involved it's not that the help isn't
needed it's that there's abundant
ability to create resources right and
once we we break that we start to be the
creator of it we create the small
non-profit that serves the area it's
like like the Matrix fails you know yeah
yeah that was long sorry oh you're good
well I have to apologize for like
chuckling when you said that part
because I was like oh wait I have a plan
to kill people too unfortunately and
then I was I used humor as my trauma
response sometimes so I strongly agree
that I have the resources and the tools
I need because I'm gonna forever be on
my healing journey and I'm always going
to look for them and find them
however therapy talk therapy I don't
think is very beneficial to a lot of
people
I think that a lot of therapists need to
learn about the nervous system because a
lot of what we went through we had to
use our fight response so I had to learn
how to calm my nervous system to get to
homeostasis the lip Baseline it's like
as a person of colors like growing up
like as an immigrant it's more like it
is what it is when you like things
happen it's like you don't really like
oh yeah go see your therapist or
anything like that especially working
through the pandemic I have never seen
like that much death yeah in in my whole
life and I've been doing this for at the
time like 10 years and this was before
the vaccine and I'm like I don't see the
end of this tunnel yet for me to quit
the job would mean other people would
die and for me to continue this job
meaning I would die and then that was
the first time I'm like I really don't
know what to do right here and that's
the first time I'm like wait there's
this thing's called therapist maybe I
should go talk to one I wish it was more
readily available and accepted at the
same time because none of my friends go
and see their therapist and I can
completely tell them like you wouldn't
have certain amount of issues if you
just kind of worked on yourself in a
different way or you might mean a
therapist but like a different way you
know what I mean yeah like coaching
right if I had to again I want to run
over here right I went in prison at 19
walked down I was 41 into a completely
different world right wow so now like my
organization path to Redemption is that
I want to provide that service like how
do how do you cope with when you walk
into a grocery store after 20 years and
you walk in the self-serving line you
got to swipe that card and you don't
know how or you walk through a line and
it beeps right and you thinking that
it's going to be tackled by the police
because they think you're stealing
something right and this is why I like
you and I and individuals can create
that
so there
not
not enough space to talk about like I
was a foster kid right so I got raised
in poverty and abuse and negative
relationships so what did I do when I
grew up I created poverty and I created
negative relationships right and that
type of a wound is such a cultural taboo
that there's not a space to talk about
that and the impacts and what do we do
and where do we go from there so um so
so come on back over here
saying I wanted to do it right I I think
that's important man and everybody in
this circle is a wounded healer and also
a servant leader right so when we see a
gap and something that's needed it's not
just us so that that's where a
tremendous opportunity is to create and
be of service to to other people like us
I would say it was dope talking to y'all
like learning the different angles of
because I was kind of like squirmish
about that title killer but listening to
all of the different facets and
challenges of it you know I really
appreciate it for me I go back to South
Carolina and go back into the Department
of Juvenile Justice and work with these
young people this is what I want to take
back right like this I want to take that
same boat man a lot of preconceived
notions we have about people I might
look at you a certain way you or you and
never would have had a clue that there's
a commonality or something we can all
relate on and learn from it's not every
day you get to meet someone that's taken
a life or you know and for me it's made
me feel alone at times and not be able
to be understood by people because of
the emotions and stuff that we have to
go through
okay
I want to send it to everybody all right